Brad Rushing, Cinematographer: This is a business
that's very important to remember you will get
hired to do what you show you can do.
Film Courage: I believe you
originally set out to be a director?
Brad: I wouldn't say I set out to
be a director you know when I was
first interested in making films.
I spent many years studying fine art fine art was
my passion and it still is my passion because to
me this is fine art in a different medium but
when I originally transitioned into thinking I
might want to do it I as as a visual artist who
is the principal author I thought well I would
want to be the auteur hence the director and that
made sense to me and so all through college that
was sort of what I was thinking and then I got
out and my first feature film that I worked on
I got on set and you know I was hustling I did
all kinds of things over the period of time this
is the job I was telling you about where I was
volunteering and I was working with professionals
and the first thing they threw at me because you
know I was a musician I did a lot of recording so
I knew sound so they had me be the boom operator
and then the sound guy had days he couldn't show
up because again we're all volunteering and and
that's another thing about volunteering because
of the attrition you step up pretty quickly so he
trained me how to record sound so I'm recording
sound and you know I learned grip work and oh the
first AC can't show up Brad you want to pull focus
you know can you run a camera I mean I went from
being the little guy to you know being the guy
that you know a couple of times it was me and the
director and a wind-up Bolex and we were the crew
so you know that was that was kind of the thing
but when I was on that job and I was watching that
director who's a friend of this day and I really
respect this guy but everybody was hitting on him
everybody on set wanted a piece of him you
know you know understandably you know the
actors wanted his time and the wardrobe
people and the producer and the location
people and it's just like you know okay and then
over here is the dp now this person has the magic
box and they get to look through the magic box
and make the pretty pictures they get the lights
the toys and I'm thinking now that that looks
like fun and the funny thing to me is is that
was that was the that was the instinct in that
moment years later looking at it retroactively
you know I have a lot of interest in science
just a huge science geek I love history and I
love music and of course visual art and I
was reflecting and I realized that all of
those disciplines converge in cinematography you
know you've got the art obviously you've got the
science in terms of the technology the physics you
know optics things like that you've got history
because you understand you know the way that that
a film was shot in the 20s versus the 40s you
understand you know the history of cameras
and film grain and digital because it all
plays in and informs your creative choices you
know if I want something with a little bit of a
retro look I have to understand that history plus
the industry's got a fascinating history and then
as in terms of music i've done a lot of camera
operating and i've come to find that there are
rhythms even if you're even if you aren't aware
of that nobody's tapping out a drum but in a scene
in my head i've got a metronome and I'm like
this person that person this person speaks they
grab the glass and I find there's a rhythm and to
reinforce this I'll tell you an interesting story
about how I cut my montages most people find
a piece of music cut to the beats of the music
I never do that to me it feels artificial it feels
forced I will cut to the rhythms of the visuals
and then I will find music that fits those
and the thing that is just profound to me
time and again is you find the right song and
it just drops into place and all those beats hit
and sometimes you maybe there's a
little nipper tuck here you know
sometimes I might cut the music and fiddle with it
a little bit but and sometimes the rhythm changes
you know we're all splicing a different piece of
music but literally all the feature montages on my
website were done that way none of them were
cut to music so so just the rhythm of it and
so all of those things converging it just made
me realize I'm not I'm not a spiritual person but
but things like that are kind of profound it's at
least magical you know when the universe conspires
or whatever it is you know even though I don't
embrace anything I don't exclude anything maybe
there is something really cool out there that
put me here but yeah that was that was kind of
the thing is that you know I made that decision
I had that impulse on that first set and then
looking back I was just overwhelmed by by all
the affirmation of why that had been the right
decision when did you realize that being a
filmmaker in Houston Texas wasn't the place
for you at that time and then what happened when
you moved here to Los Angeles it's a good question
so so obviously I started my career in the film
industry in Houston and I had you know people
I worked with who are mentors and friends and I
still do i've been back i've worked there again
I'm a big supporter of houston and of texas I'm
an advocate of the filmmaking community there
and I want to see it do well my I have
a lot of mentees there to this day
and I support the community I just actually was
invited to become a board member for southwest
alternative media project in houston which is
a film advocacy and education group that's been
around since the 70s so I'm really honored and
I feel that I'm still a part of that community
but what I did realize at the time was you know
because I knew I wanted to be a cinematographer
there wasn't any question i've always known what
I wanted to be even when I was a little kid I knew
I wanted to be a garbage man now I didn't stay
wanting to be a garbage man then I wanted to be an
astronaut but i've never been one of those people
who didn't know so I you know even though that has
swapped out and and so I knew at that time and I
thought about it and there were some really good
cinematographers in in town and still are and I
thought you know in order for me to get a shot
you know these guys are going to have to retire
or there's going to have to be more work and it
really became evident to me that it was a little
bit of a closed ecosystem it was a small market
and I thought you know I realized what a sacrifice
it was going to be I realized in terms of my free
time in terms of you know the volunteering I would
have to do to you know earn my stripes and build
my network and learn my skills just in terms of
being a freelancer and not having regular work
the uncertainty you know all of those things and I
realized okay I'm taking a big risk and that sort
of percolated in my brain and the funny thing
is I never made a calculated decision to leave
one day I walked home I didn't walk on my drove
home and I walked into the house because yeah I
was living with my parents at 25 because why not
you know I was a filmmaker they were nice people I
loved them and I was happy to be there and you
know for practical reasons I'm like you know I
have no need for that expense and I'm content so I
stayed there and I so I walked home I didn't walk
home I keep saying that I drove home and I was
walking into the house and I and I just I had this
lark that I was just gonna go provoke my parents I
was just gonna tell them that I was moving to l.a
just to get a rise out of them and I figured they
would talk me out of it and and so I walked in and
you know there had there had been no prelude
to this it had never been discussed before and
I walked in and I said i've decided to move to
los angeles and they said that's wonderful we
completely support you we think that's just such
a smart decision and and in that moment I thought
oh [ __ ] i've committed myself I have to follow
through now because again I you know but the funny
thing is you know just like I say you know maybe
sometimes the universe guides you because maybe
it was just like you know I got pushed to where
I needed to be in that moment because again it
wasn't a conscious thing but I made plans with
a camera assistant friend of mine you know to
to go out and i'd already had some friends out
here I had some filmmaker friends and I thought
okay well I'll go and I'll cast my lot with those
people you know none of them were established they
were all you know wanting to be filmmakers and
I had this one friend who said well I could come
crash on her floor and so you know my friend
and I made plans that we would leave in a month
and started thinking about it like why are we
waiting a month and I was like let's just go so
two weeks in we left so we got there and you know
living living like thieves on the on the floor and
this could be a long story but I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna fast forward
does it involve the Whisky a Go Go sorry why
do I feel like some of that's coming in no well
we were I was in Venice it was beautiful
my friend lived in a townhouse involved
okay so but anyway I got there and I had a lot
of delusions I really did I thought you know
oh and the the other reason that that it made
sense to me at the time was that you know
instead of making all these sacrifices for this
limited market if I'm going to pay this price I'm
going to go where the sky is the limit you know
that was the logic that reinforced that decision
so I get out here and I just I made so many
bad assumptions about how I was going to be
welcomed with open arms and get business and get
work and you know probably 30,000 other people had
that same idea you know and so I spent I spent
some years kind of aimlessly and you know to
make a living I was doing temp work in offices
I was doing the freebies at the time they had
this publication called dramalog which is kind of
like you know the what craigslist is today a lot
of it was student films but I'm like you know I'm
building a reel I still had a few things i'd shot
in used it but I didn't have much of a reel so you
know I just needed more footage and you know even
if I'm working for free somebody else is paying
for the film and the locations and the camera
so I did that for a while and it was really
dodgy and and at one point I had this epiphany
and I thought you know all the people I know are
at the same level I am you know we we kind of
got into this and said you know all for one and
one for all we're all going to be filmmakers
the problem with that is I realized
that if I want to make a living at this
I have to work with people who do it for
a living you know and that was a very
transformational realization for me and when I
did that that's when I started moving forward
and I started you know applying to companies
like concord new horizons one of my really
good buddies out here worked for them and he was
in the marketing department but you know he gave
me names and and pointed me in the right direction
and and that's just kind of how it got started and
you know from there it took a couple of years
and then I shot some movies for those guys
you know did some more indies a young fellow
who I mentored in houston ended up blowing up
as a huge music video director and you know
through a set of circumstances we ended up
working together and that jumped me up some
levels and then when music videos kind of
subsided I transitioned over you know the
big budgets kind of went away I transitioned
over to commercials and and then those kind of
evaporated and and now I'm doing narrative again
so you probably cut big chunks of that out no
I love the story so that that's interesting
so you're here in LA and you're you're enjoying
time with friends but you looked around and said
what is going to set me apart from these people
and that was that realization knowing that you
were working with other people that this was
paying their mortgage this was putting their kids
in school and knowing that they were going to take
it very seriously I don't know I'm paraphrasing
but well I don't know I think that the whole set
yourself apart realization came a bit later all I
realized was that I was working with wannabes
I was a wannabe my peers were one of these
you know but wanna be is if it's it's like it's
like entropy you know you're in a vacuum and and
nobody in there has the capacity to advance you
unless you get lucky it's like the lottery you
know do you you know win a festival award and even
then what does that matter you know so this is a
business that's very important to remember you
will get hired to do what you show you can do so
if all you do is freebie low budget stuff that's
what you're going to get brought on for if all you
do is volunteer stuff you know that may be what
you get stuck in if all you do is commercials
it's going to be hard to get a feature film and
even if you do commercials like me and you got a
broad variety of stuff if somebody wants a car
commercial they want the car person they want
the one with you know 10 10 car spots or you know
the beauty person I can do all of those things you
know and I have and I can show them but I don't
have the preponderance and and so that was the
thing that that you know just going back to my
early my first experience with that phenomenon
was that I was working with with one of
these people I liked people who were talented
but nobody was in a position to jump me
up to a salaried position and I had to
break outside of that paradigm you know just end
the entropy go to a completely different model
and that model was to find the people who were
getting paid to do the work and work with them
and that was really probably one of my very first
significant realizations of of you know learning
the dynamics in this industry and we basically
are all wannabes when we start out at something
so I'm still a wannabe you know there's still
things I want to do I don't say that that term
maliciously at all it's just you know we
were powerless we had no connections and
nobody was giving us money so you know it's
not a judgment it's just that was the fact.
What do you like about this video?